حلقه تفاعلكم اليوم استثنائيه نخصصها
لملخص عام كان حافل بصراحه وعناوين
العريضه الماسك نجم السنه وبدون منازع
وكابوس العنف ضد المراه لا زال مستمر اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
20 22 شرفت على النهايه كل عام وانتم بخير
وسنه جديده افضل واجمل علينا جميعا يا رب
وفي حلقتنا اليوم رح نستعرض معكم ملخص
اللي غطينا سوا على مدار السنه وفي موضوع
معين يعني سيطر اكثر من اي شيء ثاني وقصته
كلها بدات بجمله واحده قلتها في ابريل
الان ماسك اشترت تويتر
لا يتجزا من عناوين تويتر من عناوين السنه
يعني كل المجالات سياسه اقتصاد تكنولوجيا
اجتماع حقيقه كله هذا ملخص سريع للي عمله
ماسك في العالم وفي تويتر وفينا في 20 22
من حيث المستخدمين
بالنسبه للارباح وبشرنا وبشر ترامب بانه
يقدر يرجع اخيرا لتويتر
تويتر
الحسابات الوهميه اقل من 5%
في تويتر
عن نسبه الحسابات شركه طلعت وردت عليه
باختصار
هتكمل وهتتنفذ بالسعر والشروط المتفق
عليها عموما المعركه واضح انها محتدي لانه
الطرفين بيحاولوا توجيهي القضيه وفق جدول
زمني
لفت تماما عن ما يريدو الاخر بالتسجل
انتصار على ال الماسك من الجوله الاولى في
التقادم في عز ما هو في دوامه قضيه مع
تويتر اتفجرت فضيحه عاطفيه دسمه والكلام
المتداول انه ماسك سرق زوجه واحد من اعز
اصدقائه عموما ماسك انكر كل الكلام اللي
جاء في التقرير ماسكه من بعد فضيحه تويتر
اللي فجرها مسؤول الامن السابق استفاد
اكيد من اللي صار واعلن انه راح يستدعي
المسؤول في الشهاده في قضيه ومع تويتر
خلاص الجمعه راح تتم الصفقه صفقه تويتر
واهل الماسك لتصدره العناوين الاخبار
للشهور اخيرا تمت واهل خلاص سيد تويتر
الجديد بعد ما صار رئيس مو قادرين نلحق
علاج
تصريحات تغيرات ردود حل مجلس اداره تويتر
وعين نفسه الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه ناوي
ماسك يترحل لكل مقابل ثمانيه دولارات
شهريا مو عشرين مثل فاول اتنشر ما زال مصر
على رايه وبيرد شخصيا على الشكاوى
والاعتراضات فالقرار دخل حيز التنفيذ في
التحديث الجديد لنظام ايوس في ناس جلسه
بتترقب نشره اخبار الماسك اليوميه طلع
ماسك ابرر اوضح ان هو طول عمره مستقل ما
بيتبعل للجمهوريين ولا الديمقراطين ويعني
الصداع العلامه الزرقاء مستمر يعني قال
انه تويتر راح يعمل كثير من الحماقات
الاشهر المقبله حساب ترامب عاد الى تويتر
اليوم الاثنين ماسك راح يسرح مجموعه جديده
من الموظف لسلسله تغريدات قرار استعرض
فيها انجازاته في تويتر في الكم اسبوع
اللي فات فاتته استخدم كاس العالم اليوم
في حلقه جديده ضمن حلقات مسلسل قال لهم
انا الاميره الناهي والكل بحاجه الاخبار
اللي احنا بنعرض لكم هي يا دوب خلاصه ابرز
ما يتعلق فيه تويتر لانه فعليا المج
التصريحات ولت تغريدات ولا تغييرات في
الشركه من يوم ما استلمها باعلن ان راح
يطلق الشكل الجديد لميزه التوثيق يوم
الجمعه واللي راح تعتمد الالوان الذهبي
للحكومات والرمادي للشركات والازرق
للافراد ماسك خلاص اعلن الحرب على ابل
الرسميه كشف انه التقى رئيس ابل وحلوا
سواء سوء التفاهم اللي كان صاير بينهم
ماسك قال انه اي حساب بينشر معلومات عن
الموقع الحالي اي شخص راح يتم حظر نشر
استطلاع للراي طلب من متابعينه ويصوتوا
على انه يبقى في تويتر رئيس
وقال ان هو ملتزم بالنتائج الاستطلاع
الاستثمار راح يتنعها الا لما نلاقي شخص
احمق كفايه علشان يستلم رئاسه تويتر بداله
طيب مشاهدينا اللي شفتهم ملخص والله
العظيم ملخص ركزوا لي على كلمه ملخص اعتقد
يعني بعد اللي شفته سمعتوه وتابعته على
مدارس السلام ما حد تختلفوا معنا لما نسمي
الماسك نجم 20 22 وبدون منازع وبدون منازع
كمان ماسكين اكثر اسم قلته في السنه واللي
مو مصدق يسمع
شراء تويتر تويتر
نشره اخبار المسك اللي حسب ماسك تغريده ال
الماسك اللي سلخه
رئيس الحالي اهل مصر الان سيد تويتر
الجديد
[موسيقى]
رغم انه امنيات نفرين 21 كانت غير كده في
20 21 العنف ضد المراه والجرائم
والاعتداءات عليها كانت من ملفاتنا
الرئيسيه على مدار السنه واتمنينا انه
يكون 20 22 مختلف لكن للاسف الكابوس مكمل
ومشكله
هو احنا في اجتماعنا التحريري اليومي
كفريق عمل تفاعلكم اصابتنا حاله صدمه
واكتئاب من الكم الهاء من العناوين عن
الجرائم اللي بتصير بالجمله من حوالينا
والقزم المشترك بينها انه الضحيه هي انثى
ولونها جميل علي حيدر طفله يمنيه عمرها
عشر سنوات ضحيه جديده من ضحايا زواج
القاصرات في اليمن الجريمه البشعه اللي
راحت ضحيتها طالبه في جامعه المنصوره
اسمها نيره اشرف بعد ما قلت لها زميل لها
امام رصيف الجامعه الجديد اليوم مقطع
فيديو متداول بشكل واسع لجثه نيره اعطيني
اللي بيشوف محمد عادل ضحيه ومظلوم نسخه
جديده منير اشرف اللي قتلت في المنصوره
لكن باسم جديده هذه المره عندنا اشرف في
الشرقيه
لكن طلعت انباء بتقول انه عائلتها هي اللي
قتلتها لرفضها تركبها والزواج من اخر هي
العروس اسمها محمد اللي ضربها زوجها وهي
عن الصالون التجميل في يوم فرحها هي رفعت
قضيه على زوجها واستغاطت بالسلطه اماني
الجزار وهي فتاه من المنوفيه في مصر
بيتصدر كل منصات بعد تداول فيديو لمقتلها
على يد شاب رفضت الارتباط فيه قصه مقتل
الطالبه المصريه اماني الجزار لسه متصدر
العناوين بعد ما انتحر قاتلها بعد جريمه
بساعات شيماء جمال اللي قتلت على يد زوجها
وتطورات قضيه مقتل الاعلاميه شيماء جمال
كشفت تفاصيل يعني مفجعه بتزيد من الصدمه
باكثر من طريقه واسلام محمد
بقتل زميلته سلمى بهجه الشوات في 20 طعنه
بالسكين تاجر مصري قتل زوجته وتخلص من
جثتها في منطقه صحراويه ورحمه
المهول ضد في العالم العربي الاردني ايمان
رشاد اللي قتلت من كم يوم بست رصاصات داخل
حرم جامعه العلوم التطبيقيه في عمان من
وقتها هرب القاتل لغايه مالاغو امس متخبي
في احد المزارع ولما نحاصروه اطلق النار
على نفسه وانتحرنا اللي قتلها زوجها اللي
رافعه ضده دعوه طلاق بعد ما طعمها 16 مره
هذا غير اليمنيه اللي ينظف من حافله هربا
من اغتصاب السائق لها انتصار المختطفه من
فبراير العامل الماضي من وسط العاصمه
صنعاء برفقه زميلاتها بتتعرض للتعذيب
والضرب المبرح عاد عن حلق الحوثي لشعرها
كاملا حتى اصبحت صلعه كل هذه الجرائم سؤال
واحد كذب يعني بيخطر في بالنا ايش بيصير
في العالم
ومن عنق الى عنف بس بدل ما هو اجتماعي
الان سياسي وعسكري الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه حدث عالمي كان من الاهم وللاسف
مستمر ومسيطر على الاخبار وملف كان من دون
شك من اكثر ما تكلم عنه العالم في 20 22
الاسماء الرو
سيه اقتراب قبول الحرب واحتماليات غزو
روسيا
للشكل هذا اكثر موضوع مسيطر على العالم
وعناوين الاخبار الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
ما بدات فعليا يعني للان على الاقل
بتتوقعوا انه روسيا
اوكرانيا بحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بدات العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في
روسيا اليوم نفذت روسيا هجمات
اللي صار للجسر الاستراتيجي والحرب
العالميه الثالثه
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد من عناوين سيطره على اخبار
العالم ككل الى عناوين خاصه فينا في
تفاعلكم اكثر يعني هذه السنه كانت مليئه
بالمواضيع والضيوف اللي شرفونا في كل
حلقاتنا خلينا نتوقف مع جوله سريعه مع
النجوم اللي كانوا ضيوفنا في 20 سنه 20
عمر
انسان في الاستوديو الفنانه مرام علي اهلا
فيك معنا مرام اجمل الاشياء في وظيفتي الي
اقدر التقي الفنانين رائعين مثلك نحن
بنرجع وبنقول لك الف الف مبروك على هذا
الانجاز اسعدنا وانا يعني من اشد المعجبين
فيك وان شاء الله المره الجايه اشوفك وانت
بتحققي جراند سلام ماجده الصباح رائده
الاعمال ومؤسسه مبادره هنا
شكرا لك شكرا على الترقيه
اهلا فيك معنا يا منه
يا شباب
نورتنا دكتور اشرف اشتقت لك كثير يا ساره
النجم جمال سليمان اهلين فيك معانا كل عام
وانت بالف خير والامه العربيه بالف خير
مبروك كل هذه الاصداء ميرسي يا ساره
اهلين
طيب خلال اللقاءات اللي شفتوها مع النجوم
اكثر منهم خلصونا بتصريحات حصريه او
مفاجات او اخبار جديده تفاعلكم كان له
ايضا السبق في مقابلات وتصريحات في مواضيع
اخرى عديده همت الراي العام
محمد عبده
الياسمين
الثانيه
حياتي الشخصيه مستحيل ان انا اتكلم فيها
مش شخصيه لي انا لوحدي في طرف ثاني فيها
وقعتك كمان ممكن تتكلم يعني انه تقول ممكن
صادق الشاعر يعني بس ما جبت سيرته بس مو
مشكله صادق الشاعر وسهم
لك 67 سنه قاعده تلفي على السؤال ترى ههه
يعني هافضل ادير ادول في الموضوع ده طيب
هو هو ممتان لك جدا على فكره
[موسيقى]
امتناني على اهتمامه كله يعني
قالوا انه التبرعات هتروح رواتب ليه
موظفين المفوضيه هل هذا صحيح
ابدا ابدا غير صحيح
انه اه تحيه لزوجي وكذا ايوه صار كل واحد
يبعث يقول زوجها من زوجها فين
يشتغل والتحقيقات
زوجي بنتي ابني اذا ما عندهم يظهرون فانا
احترم خصيتهم منتشره صوره له ودائما
يقولوا انه هذا ابنه نايف معه وكذا وانه
هذا ابنه وحيد هل هذه الصوره حقيقيه
لا لا لا الولد هذا الله يخليه له هلا هذا
ابن الشاعر والله ما يحسبني اسمها اللي
اللي كتب الاوبريت
كبير كرزون
ولا يجي
خلصنا منها
ان ده ضابط اسرائيلي يعني
وتم اغتياله يعني ما فهمتش الحقيقه بس انا
اخذتها الضحك
كثير اغلى منك
فوق راسي
من الالكترونيه ورفعت قضيه على الشخص او
الجهه اللي همم طلع الاشاعه والزوجوا لها
واللي علق وعليها واللي شيروها لانه هذول
ايضا وينشركاء بالجريمه في عالم رجل طبعا
نحن في عالم رجل
الممثل الفنان الممثل حتى لو كنتي انت
مثلا اعلى منه نجوميه هو بياخذ اكثر طبعا
لا زالت تعلق عليك وتلمح مثلا احيانا
صراحه بالاسم واحيانا تلميحات وما الى ذلك
ليش مستمر هذا الصراع
الله اعلم
ما عندي تعليق انت رفعتي عليها قضيه
كلنا حبايبها يا الهام قد ناس تدري عارفه
في قضايا وايد
[ضحك]
وبتقطعوها والفران
فنان كبير
يعني هو انت لوحدك مفاجاه جميله جدا
المفاجاه الجميله الي معك الله الله الله
الله
اهلا اهلا بالست جليله ازيك يا حبيبتي
طبعا انا لسه ههه لسه بمر فيها لسه شغاله
يعني الحمد لله ههه
بصي المسلسل
طبعا اكيد حلال طيب وشو وين لا شهود راح
يكونوا على التلفون
للوطن العربي وهذا فخر لي انا مسامحك من
قلبي وهو نفسه لو عايش كان اخذ الموضوع
بطريقه لطيفه
من قبل عدد كبير من الاشخاص طلاب زائد
حسابات وهميه في دول ممكن ينتقل من حدا
لحدا بس بالنهايه بده ينشغل انت يمكن اول
فنانه اقابلها ترد هذا الرد
العظيم رد
طيب اللي يعرفني يعرف علاقتي القويه مع
الغناء
كمستمع فقط يعني كان نفسي يكون عندي موهبه
اكبر من كده بس للاسف يعني قدر الله وما
شاء فعل هذا اللي موجود يعني فريق تفاعلكم
حابه انه يذكرني بوجع وحسرتي ويذكروني زي
ما دايما بيذكروني تقريبا كل يوم لما اغني
لهم انه صوتي بشعر واختاروا انه نختم حلقه
ملخص السنه باجمل اصوات النجوم اللي كانوا
ضيوفنا الثانيه
ان شاء الله في امان الله
يا بحر يا ابو الاسرار
مثلك مثل اللي
الي
مشتاق لهن قلبي على نار بدي شوف
الغوالي وخدني صوب وديني
اشلحني عندهن ونسينا
بتفعلك كل سنين
وبقضي عمري يغني لك
قد عمري يغني
همم
اشوف فيك يوم
على اللي انت عملته فيا
لما انت دارت بيا
واللي بترضى عليا بكره النهارده عليك
تذكر اي شيء
[موسيقى]
وان كان يحصلك
تناسيها ايش عجب قاطع بيه يا راحتي
النفسيه
تدري القلب
مش هز في المدام مش خايف ليه في الخصام ده
لو عينيك شطفت عيني امشي وما ترميني
السلام
واتنسيت كاني ما جيت ولو حسيتها تكسر
وداريت في قلبي مشيت على عيني تغربني
[موسيقى]
عطشان يا برق السماء بموت من طول الغياب
بموت من كثر الظلمات وانا على متن الصحاب
خطاك في عيوني صوره حبك بقلبي من تحت
مكتوب ومقدر كتاب لكشف حجري من ناحيه الله
عليك
لا لا انا وجهه غلاف السنه
انا عندي الخلاف حرفنه
لو هتسال
[موسيقى]